hi my name is Jeff Sharkey and I'm a
student from Montana State University I
wrote an Android application called
compare everywhere and I'd like to show
it to you on my phone today let's go
ahead and get it started up and when we
open it we have three different options
we could scan a barcode run a full text
search or look at lists of items that we
might have stored before in the past in
this case I found a CD that I'm
interested in we can tap and scan the
barcode with our phone so in this case
we found several different options for
going out and buying this item we can
look through that list we see there's
several online stores and also some
local stores in our neighborhood as well
as a local library that we could go and
borrow the item in this case we can also
map those local stores to look at all of
the different options if I know I'm
going down to a neighborhood later today
I could zoom in to see what stores are
available in the area and what prices
they have in this case I'm interested in
this store I can tap on that and I can
look at see driving directions to the
store location or I could call them to
make sure that they actually have it in
stock I can also look at lists of items
so let's say like a shopping list as I
walk through the store if I know I need
to pick up a certain number of items I
can easily cross those items off my list
as I buy them as I walk through the
store so I got the idea for this
application a couple years ago as I was
watching a documentary I saw an employee
in a store scan a barcode and be able to
check the inventory that they had in the
back room as well as the pricing they'd
had over the past couple years I thought
to myself why couldn't people everywhere
have that kind of functionality on their
phones as they walk through stores so to
build this application I use several
different api's pieced together I use
the camera that's built into the phone
along with the zebra crossing library
which is an open-source library written
by several people at Google I to decode
the barcodes I also used the Google Maps
API to be able to show the local stores
in a person's area and finally I used
the location manager to make sure that
we always select local stores that are
around the user in all using those API
is it only took me about two white two
weeks to write